hey guys my name is Eric I'm new here
and recently I made some friends by
giving out vodka filled chocolate that I
used to eat Russia it worked well so I'm
just gonna keep giving out treats looks
like people in America loves sriracha
sauce and dippin dots so I'm gonna make
sriracha dippin dots so to make dippin
dots you need some liquid nitrogen which
isn't allowed in the office I don't know
why so I just had them deliver it to my
friend's place what the hell they told
me who's gonna be a small can once again
just ordered a bunch of missiles
all right luckily they had a smaller one
for me so let's bring it in what's Happ
I'm here y'all fixin to the doctors dude
no way what so we ended up in the
backyard
let's turn this on is that
let me see justify drop it
nope that didn't do anything I put
sriracha no it needs to be liquid oh my
god there's liquid in there
oh my god it's making balls put some
ranch in spicy we're gonna do a quick
taste test before I go and let people
try it oh it's exactly what sriracha so
I can't go till I drain this whole
freaking tank
[Music]
I always mean you made dippin dots man
this looks like something and blue
cheese looks like little meats this is
baby food
it's in like a cage it's a sriracha
dipping that cuz that's disgusting the
fact that there's such a small amount is
really frightening to me I don't think
you're trying to make friends anymore I
think you're trying to slowly kill off
your coworker so you can take all their
jobs all right here we go
sriracha ice cream dick it's not awful
I'm sorry I should put that out that was
rude that's good actually
you want some yes see I like spicy food
and I actually can get down with that
please don't do this again
did I just oh oh oh my senses bring me
something good next my lips are burning
there now I got to go brush my lips I'm
actually proud of what I made so I'm
gonna give it to someone who knows
what's up tasty producers
oh my god but good why Eric be quiet
thought we were going somewhere I
listened so hard oh yes going and I put
in I even put ranch jerk get out of the
kitchen get out of here I see be ready
hopefully it's it's not really good you
gotta do it I believe in you ready I'm
gonna guide it I'm gonna die in it ready
[Music]
that's right exactly
we're gonna turn this into a business
you want to be my partner we're doing it
we're doing oh oh